I would define compassion in a nutshell,
as a natural sense of concern that
arises in us in the face of someone who
was a need or someone who's in pain and
accompanied by a kind of a wishing to
see the relief or end of that situation
and wanted to do something about it.
So it's compassionate.
It's not just an emotional reaction.
There is also a more motivational kind
of element which makes us want to do
something about the situation.
One of the interesting thing about our
contemporary modern society is that I'm
given the highly competitive nature of
society and also the way in which we're
bringing up our children and the way in
which we ourselves grew up,
which involved huge amount of evaluation
and judgment and comparison across with
others from a very early age.
Um,
we have kind of internalized a certain
kind of way of being in the world and
perceiving our relationship with others.
And that dynamic has created a certain
kind of,
you know,
inhibitions against our natural
compassionate instinct.
So,
and these inhibitions really take
primarily in the form of fear.
So for example,
many people worry and I'm afraid that if
they are too kind and compassionate,
that other people will take advantage of
them.
They will see them as pushover or weak
or losers.
So that's one type of fear that we
bring.
I'm not the type of fear that we bring
is that,
um,
you know,
because in popular understanding of
compassion,
it's so dominated by compassion as an
emotion,
kind of a soft heart and tender heart
and so on.
So people worry that if they allow their
compassionate and kinder instinct to
become more dominant in their way of
interacting with the world and others,
you know,
somehow it might undermine their more
rational,
tougher aside so that they may not be
able to succeed in the life and compete.
That's another type of fear.
And then sometimes,
uh,
in intimate relations that particularly
between parents and children on the part
of the parents,
sometimes we also worry that if we were
to kind to our children,
you know,
we might be spoiling them,
we,
they might become overdependent up on us
and then somehow we will end up having
to do everything for them.
So these are various types of fear that
we bring into our expression of natural
compassionate instinct.
And a lot of these are subconscious
biases that we bring.
You know,
people may not necessarily sit down and
think that's what I'm going to do,
but these are culturally acquired
sensibilities and biases,
which also makes us suspicious when
someone has been kind to us
compassionate towards us,
we start one wondering,
there must be hidden agenda,
you know,
that that person must want something
from me.
So it's,
I'm very unfortunate.
These are various forms of culturally
acquired fear that really undermines the
expression of what is really natural to
our human being,
which is the ability to connect with
someone and the ability to relate to
that person at a deeper level and have a
much more open heart hearted kind of
interaction.